what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Avengers versus X-men the
versus series individual fights between
these characters and we have Spider-Man
versus Colossus not only that it's
Spider-Man versus the Unstoppable
Colossus so as always a little bit of
explanation here and if you need to get
caught up make sure you click the link
to the playlist at the end of this video
the entirety behind Avengers versus
X-men is that a girl named Hope Summers
the first mut and born after House of M
is basically going to become the Phoenix
and the fear of the Avengers is that as
the Phoenix she'll lay waste to life on
Earth but the X-Men because they not
only see her as one of their own but
because her existence is so incredibly
important to the future of the X-Men and
really the mutant population on Earth
refused to hand her over that led to a
fight and so what you do here is you
initially pick up with Spider-Man kind
of bobbing and weaving between what
Colossus is trying to do what just to
say attack him and he even makes this
common right he's like serious though
armor over steel skin can you say
Overkill right like we need to get you
on Project Runway ASAP but for all the
joking this is not just regular Colossus
with osmium skin this is Unstoppable
Colossus so how did he get to this point
right so in Marvel Comics they had a
story called fear itself and the long
and short of the explanation for this is
that Colossus as you know him was just
always the Colossus that we always knew
going into that story but that revolved
around guy who was really just kind of
like the long lost brother of Odin known
as the serpent when this guy emerged he
basically started giving hammers to
different people out there so they could
serve in his army but also start reaping
and sewing chaos the Juggernaut got one
of those Hammers and he received a power
boost because of it in order to find a
way to defeat the Juggernaut Colossus
and his sister magic went to the realm
of citak the guy who traditionally
Powers the Juggernaut through the
Crimson gym and and by showing them what
Juggernaut was doing on Earth it was
really just citak getting jealous and
seeing Juggernaut is using a power other
than the one that was given to him and
so what citak did is he took away Cain
Marco's ability to operate as his kind
of envoy on Earth and gave Colossus the
Crimson gym which in turn turned
Colossus into the Unstoppable Colossus
so he's basically an answer to the
question what would happen if Colossus
had the powers of the Juggernaut It's
pretty dope this guy is in insanely
powerful and so one of the things to
know is that even with this being the
case he's not like Kan Marco where he's
almost like a sociopath destroying
everything in its path and relishing in
it instead he doesn't actually want to
kill Spider-Man and even while the two
of them are here dealing with what are
in effect these kind of robotic forces
that are trying to bring the conflict to
an end none of it's going to happen and
none of it's really going to have
anything going on we do get this kind of
little fun fact which is something that
you guys may not have known that spider
fluid is too or at least is over 2 and 1
half times as strong as steel long time
Spider-Man fans have known that right
but new folks may not and so Spider-Man
picks up pretty quickly that Unstoppable
Colossus is basically the Juggernaut and
so he even asks like want to know how
this goes down I blind you for a bit you
get all annoyed since you can't hit me I
Tire myself out punching you for 800
million hours eventually I trick you
into falling into some half set concrete
a bottomless pit or an inexplicable that
of molten marshmallow sorry for the
spoilers but one of the things to know
here and and a lot of people will look
at this if you're not overly familiar
with Spider-Man don't look at this and
say there's no conceivable way that this
guy could stand a chance against
Unstoppable Colossus and yeah like the
Juggernaut is incredibly fast due to the
powers that he has and really Colossus
himself is actually faster now not just
because of the powers of the Juggernaut
but also because of his own abilities
they don't traditionally speed him up
but like training and all that kind of
stuff just sort of enhances what he was
originally capable of back when he was
first introduced in Marvel Comics but
the thing about this is Spider-Man has
the one thing that allows him to
overcome and really even go toe-to-toe
with various characters out there that
would otherwise destroy him and that's
his Spider Sense and his agility that's
one of the things that I want you guys
to notice here he's not really relying
much on brute strength because there is
only so much he can do his ability to
punch Colossus is really just kind of
limited to like maybe irritating him or
kind of softening him up a little bit
but it's not as though Spider-Man's
going to be able to like one-hot
Unstoppable Colossus that's just not
going to happen and so what he ends up
doing is kind of webbing him up doing
what he can but at the end of the day it
still doesn't matter Unstoppable
Colossus ends up coming out just
clapping his hands creating a Sonic
punch which is or at least a sonic boom
which is enough to kind of send
Spider-Man flying but it's not enough
enough to destroy him now one of the
other things that I want to specify here
is that Marvel officially lists these
kind of robotic guys out here that are
trying to quell the conflict as being
doombots because they are fighting in
Latveria they're not really traditional
doombots right they're not really
doombots as you normally know them and
that's because Dr Doom kind of has a few
different versions of those right he's
got like your old school doombots from
like way back when then he's just kind
of got like your regular robots right
the old school doombots are just kind of
like the ones that look like Dr Doom and
sometimes they believe they're Dr Doom
depending on how they're programmed and
whatnot but with these robots they're
more just kind of like a localized
police force right like flatfoots for
those of you guys out here who don't
know the the name of cops that walk the
beach but the fact remains like
literally Colossus just like grabs these
robots and just starts hurling them at
Spider-Man which allows him to operate
with some kind of a distraction because
Spider-Man's kind of bobbing and weaving
but he's also a superhero so what he's
trying to do is Bob and weave weave out
of the way of these robots that are
flying into him while also making sure
they don't hit other people and create
collateral damage now Colossus himself
was always an empathetic character so
you could make an argument that he's not
really looking to hurt other people but
hurling robots at someone while they're
dodging out of the way would probably
lead to Collateral
Damage and some capacity but even when
Colossus gets his hands on Spider-Man
Spider-Man continues to crack jokes now
the reason why this is one of the most
important things for years and years in
Marvel Comics we didn't fully know why
he cracked jokes and even at the time
the story was being written we didn't
definitively know it was largely assumed
by really Spider-Man fans that he did it
to get under the skin of his guys but
that was really more rooted in like
tropes right like characters like
Spider-Man who crack jokes while they're
fighting to convince the guys they're
fighting that they're not actually
taking the conflict seriously it wasn't
until renew your vows that we actually
learned learned that was the truth that
Spider-Man's cracking jokes here when
he's fighting Colossus because he wants
Colossus to believe he doesn't take him
seriously but Colossus doesn't care he
doesn't buy in to any of that Malarkey
and instead he just keeps on taking it
to Spider-Man even when Spider-Man like
throws one of these robots back at him
it doesn't make any difference and he
just tells him give up before I lose
control before I kill you now that's one
of the things to know is that with
unstoppable Colossus a lot of the story
that was going on with his character up
to this point in time dealt with some
mental instability right not that he was
like a guy who was a sociopath or a
psychopath but in the sense that it's
hard for him to maintain this extreme
amount of Rage because that's part of
what it means to be a host for the
Crimson gym of citak It kind of feeds on
your rage and it feeds on your anger and
so at all times Colossus kind of had to
keep himself under control keep himself
in check otherwise he would just
completely lose it be over inomed with
rage and lose his mind and so that's
where Spider-Man kind of chimes in it
says not a chance that's the other thing
about the Juggy Spidey brawl you're
unstoppable well guess what that means I
have to be unstoppable too the problem
with this is that Daredevil kind of
shows up and says Hope's not here and
then Spider-Man takes off and this was
just kind of an out for Marvel because
if we're being honest with ourselves no
way Marvel Comics is going to tell a
story where the face of the company gets
absolutely crushed by any other guy out
there that's not going to happen I mean
let's be honest with ourselves I'm not
even going to ask for opinions on who
you think would win if this fight went
on long enough Colossus would have
killed Spider-Man like he would have
beat him to death like there's no way
that that was not going to happen I mean
it's just because Colossus would have
just lost control and Spider-Man just
simply cannot hold up against the
strength of someone like Unstoppable
Colossus because again with the power of
the Juggernaut he can fight in depth
defitely he doesn't need food doesn't
need water doesn't doesn't need sleep or
anything like that his energy goes on
forever so Spider-Man would wear down
Colossus would not and that would be the
end of it but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end let
me know down in the comments section who
you think would win I guess now I'm
asking for an opinion and if you need to
get caught
up on Avengers versus X-men at least the
versus fight make sure you click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace